hi i'm roy chang and this is gq shopping
spree let's get materialistic
what you got pick
we got infinite money and we still have
to pick what's the point of having
infinite money if you have to pick
[Music]
okay sports memorabilia that's what i'm
talking about you guys did your research
are you guys looking at my browsing
history
if you are please stop
i respect collecting game-worn jerseys
but living in new york city we don't
have the space to collect
square footage in new york is crazy i
don't buy a storage unit just to store
my stuff i want to look at it oh man
right here this would be okay michael
jordan signed jersey the dream team usa
jersey signed by michael jordan i don't
care what the price is you buy this this
is sports history this is american
history right here whatever the price is
just buy this immediately team usa 1992
dream team
the greatest basketball team ever
assembled you buy this okay
add it to cart okay sure jeremy lynn
autographed signed nba basketball yeah
okay you buy this even if you live in
new york apartment 595.95
[Music]
why is this on discount first of all why
is there a discount on this this
shouldn't be discounted okay you pay
full price for this certificate of
authenticity provided by jsa new york
city apartment or not you buy this you
put it in your freaking living room okay
on that stand with the with the glass
with the plastic box
added georgia st pierre ufc autograph
2014 tops ufc knockout red parallel
hashtag k-a-g-s-p
11-15 cod with rush
okay it's a card you can you know you
can store it away easy it's not gonna
take up a lot of space okay fine two
thousand two hundred forty nine dollars
and ninety nine cents yeah okay also
when did i did i become too old too
quickly because when did we start
putting cards in these cases suddenly it
definitely keeps it from being like
folded in half by your mom accidentally
while she's cleaning your room
[Music]
you got me on the sports memorabilia
damn it man come on the giannios
milwaukee bucks autographed game used
red nike shoe versus boston celtics on
march 24th and 26th 20 000. it's
essentially just a bunch of plastic
sitting in your house there's a lifespan
on these things they decay after like 12
years 15 years they start becoming like
would i buy this yes absolutely i think
this was his
mvp year right if someone won the mvp
you buy the goddamn shoe they were
playing any game that season okay that's
the rules i don't make them just buy it
if you respect basketball you respect
athletes you buy these shoes
unfortunately you have to pick one of
these items
oh what you got pick
we got infinite money and we still have
to pick we have to choose things then
you gotta go with the michael jordan
dream team sign jersey i love you gsp
but michael jordan signed jersey yes
let's just say i found some cool watches
and i bought some once i've since
decided to stop doing it because it's a
rabbit hole but uh at one point during
the pandemic yes i was looking
obsessively at watches jacob and co
astronomia solar baguette 480 thousand
dollars even with infinite money i don't
think i could drop like half a mil on a
watch you get mugged immediately in new
york city this is just a crime magnet
over here it's definitely well made and
there's lots going on here a little hard
to actually tell the time i would say
although if you want to see where you
are in the solar system this watch would
um definitely help keep track of that in
case you lose track of which planet
you're on i'm gonna have to say uh no i
would probably skipped this one i think
i can get more bang for my buck with
half a million dollars than this watch
i'm gonna spend the infinite money on
maybe something else next up oof hublob
big bang king power anderson silver
spider bang limited edition chrono put
bang in there twice that's how banging
this watch is twelve thousand nine
hundred ninety five dollars i'm gonna
say no to this watch it's tough to pair
spider web with whatever you're wearing
oh only 100 pieces ever made yeah i
still know i think no i think passing
this maybe if they put like a third bang
in the name i would have gone for it but
two bangs just wasn't enough okay omega
speedmaster ed white there you go this
is way more up my alley 37 000
yeah this is the one i think this is the
one well first of all it's all scratched
up so you know it's
expensive watches are made for wearing
so i never want to buy a watch where you
just put it in a safe somewhere the
speedmaster famously was used by
astronauts to go to the moon why
wouldn't you want to be associated with
that i mean these guys went to the moon
with this watch you can
you know you can get to your train on
time if you wear this watch yeah this is
where my also a
a mere 37 thousand dollars like 37 000
over divided by infinity times 100 is
still like it's nothing you've got tons
of money left over next okay i stout
rolex datejust 21 799.99
it looks cheaper that way very classic
rolex everyone has it my dad had one i
mean if you did this to my dad's watch
he would be like that's awesome and then
he would sell it because no he wouldn't
wear this i don't think you wear this
hey man what what a man or woman does
with
his or her watch is i respect the
personalization of what you own a lot of
what i buy is based on not being mugged
in new york city so i like to get stuff
that i can actually wear out this
i don't think i could wear out houston
human endeavor to go to the moon
original vintage 1965 speedmaster ed
white available for 37 000 in mint
condition next okay roseburn edinburgh
scotland that's enough for me to say no
eight bedrooms seven bathrooms
six million five hundred
eleven thousand two hundred and sixty
four dollars these pictures make it look
good but what does it look like in real
life look if they even made it up like a
scottish grandmother the interior design
so that really makes me want to not buy
it let's just say your boy is not well
liked in the uk too many bad memories
beautiful city but too many bad memories
performing stand-up comedy moving on
upper west side manhattan new york
65 million dollars i love how i'm being
so picky and i'm still like so is that
subway west side great west side all the
subways so this location kills it
already it looks like there's a working
chimney which you why would you ever do
that it looks haunted this looks like
you'll be dealing with ghosts 65 million
dollars but has a ghost
can we get rid of the old books though
is that does it come with the books or
do you have to read these books if you
buy this place is that a walk-in closet
is that a doorman i don't know why it's
so hard for me to commit to this seven
floors high but how many bathrooms eight
beds and ten baths plenty of room to
store your board's memorabilia
if you get an opportunity to get a
building in new york
like i think you should just get it
because nothing will lower the prices of
new york real estate and i mean nothing
so just get it get this building okay
melbourne australia 4 million
and
84
four dollars yeah you get this for sure
i lived in melbourne for ten years it's
a great city to live in great food
options uh very safe and friendly great
for kids three baths
yeah that's enough come to the piano the
living room the whole thing stretches
out it's not like weird compartments
floor-to-ceiling windows yeah this is
this is a no-brainer i think four
million dollars infinite money
you get it
what would you say is the optimal number
of bathrooms you want one for every
bedroom and then one for guests so that
they don't have to [ __ ] in your bedroom
bedroom plus one may we all be so lucky
to have guests over who don't have the
[ __ ] in your bedroom next sentosa cove
singapore 14 million 638 811
singapore
safe country no guns free health care
free education the basics needed for
human survival which um unfortunately we
don't
have in america sentosa is like
disney world you're living in a resort
island that's off of singapore which
depending on your personality type could
be awesome or awful you should be aware
that you have you might be surrounded by
tourists all the time four bedrooms
three bathrooms so that's one less than
the equation i gave you so you have
people sitting in
bedrooms it's got a ladder it's got a
bookcase with a ladder so you know it's
expensive this is a good buy it looks
nice if you're not living in an
apartment building in singapore you are
bawling so i guess it's new york rules
wine cellar probably use it to keep my
sports memorabilia i'll probably turn
that into a toilet
so that my guests can go there instead
of going to my bedroom
so i love living in manhattan 90 of the
time if it was a new york place i get it
for some reason this one building really
is giving me some creepy um ghostbusters
2 vibes oh man i'm gonna have to go with
the south melbourne australia great
place to live this location is great i'm
gonna have to go with this one also my
wife is australian so she'd probably be
very unhappy if i picked any other of
these places
this is highly unusual
prince albert victor's strand of hair
519 dollars a guaranteed genuine half
inch strand of prince albert victor's
hair how did they get this
just no straight no this is an easy note
to this one i spent half the time trying
to get hair off my apartment my roomba
would take care of this in like five
seconds this guy was jack the river oh
what oh this is the dude this is the
jack the ripper prince then even more so
no that's just bad vibes okay this will
get caught in the drain immediately you
have to call the plumber
this no this is very bad for your pipes
next up british royal officers uniform
no i don't want this it probably smells
i'm guessing they didn't have great dry
cleaning technology back then six
thousand five hundred dollars yeah i
know i'm i'm cool i'm good thanks
buckingham palace slogin why is it isn't
jin supposed to be clear why is this the
color of blood 30 pounds so they took
berries on campus and put it in that
buckingham palace gin to make this
palette is medium sweet with flavor
characters so plum marzipan and
bitterness from citrus followed by
juniper and ginger spices ah no thank
you thank you for offering but no mr
bean full head latex mask 24.99 no again
no why this is awful and uh
i would not buy this i think it's going
to end up in a river somewhere after you
wear it once and throw it away so no
this is not environmentally friendly
british summary which of these would i
buy if you force me at gunpoint like an
american to buy one of these things i'd
have to go with the buckingham palace
slogin i guess
right the most consumable of items at
least you can kind of close your eyes
drink it and get rid of it
okay trips let's check out some
vacations yacht week croatia one
thousand forty three dollars per person
okay you go on a yacht no i get seasick
a little easily so seven days on a yacht
actually sounds like torture i think i'm
good moving on rewilding scotland eco
trips six thousand four hundred fifty
dollars per person eco trips i love the
idea of it i'm in a phase of my life
where i actually might not hate camping
anymore this isn't that bad i mean i'm
not hating this just don't ask me to
perform in the city but visit i love it
i got friends there why not acticat
rainforest glamping in costa rica 130
per night this looks closer to camping
than glamping hey you know what yeah
okay sure costa rica i've always wanted
to go to uh because tom brady goes there
tom brady sells it for me ensuite
bathroom camping with a bathroom that
that's all i need yeah costa rica
rainforest glam thing yeah i'll do this
at tocott okay north pole in luxury 16
day expedition
43
321
oof ice breaking that's probably not a
good thing for the rest of the world but
it is hybrid powered so i guess that
balances it out i gotta admit these
photos aren't doing it for me uh this
looks kind of bleak uh these guys look
kind of miserable uh it looks super cold
the fact that we are destroying
the ice up there is probably not a good
idea either sounds less of a holiday and
more of like a
like a historical journey that you read
about where everyone dies so i'm going
to say no to this trip summary i think
that was a clear choices between
edinburgh or costa rica so i'm gonna go
with costa rica rainforest glamping but
we got infinite money so we should be
adding the extras to this you know what
i mean this sounds like the base package
let's let's put in the extras let's have
walls in costa rica okay thanks everyone
thanks for taking me on a shopping spree
youtube did your research into what i
hate and made me choose amongst that so
thank you uh i'll see you next time